في المستقبل غير البعيد ،
ستحتفل أوكرانيا بـ 500 يوم منذ
الغزو الروسي ، يقاتل الأوكرانيون من أجل
حياتهم ، لكن يتساءل الكثيرون عما إذا كان
داعمو كييف الغربيون سيصابون بإرهاق الحرب ،
يشرف جيك سوليفان على دور أمريكا في
الحرب في أوكرانيا الآن أكثر من
مقابلتي مع  له جيك
عندما تفكر في
الهجوم المضاد الأوكراني ،
ما الذي تبحث عنه فقط لترى
أن الاستثمارات الضخمة التي
قامت بها الولايات المتحدة في مساعدة
أوكرانيا تؤتي ثمارها
جيدًا أولاً ، هذا ليس اختبارًا
لا نحدده  هجوم أوكرانيا المضاد
والقول إنك تعلم أنك قمت بعمل جيد بناءً
على ما قدمناه لك أو أنك فعلت بشكل سيئ
ما نريد فعله هو دعم أوكرانيا لتحقيق
أكبر قدر ممكن من التقدم في
ساحة المعركة بحيث تكون في
أقوى موقع ممكن في
طاولة المفاوضات ونعتقد أن
هذا الهجوم المضاد سيسمح
لأوكرانيا
باستعادة الأراضي ذات الأهمية الاستراتيجية من
المناطق الروسية التي تحتلها روسيا والتي هي
حقًا أراضي أوكرانية ذات سيادة ، وكم
بالضبط في الأماكن التي
ستكون على مستوى التطورات على الأرض
مثل الأوكرانيين  ابدأ هذا
الهجوم المضاد ، لكننا
نعتقد أن الأوكرانيين سيواجهون
النجاح في هذا الهجوم المضاد
وسنواصل دعمهم وهم
يسعون للدفاع عن أنفسهم ضد
العدوان الروسي المستمر ولكن كما
تشير ضمنيًا في ردك على
النجاح  تأمل أن
تترجم بعد ذلك إلى موقف تفاوضي قوي ،
لذلك تتوقع ربما بحلول
نهاية هذا العام أن تكون هناك
مفاوضات حول نوع من
الهدنة أو صفقة من نوع ما ،
ولن أضع جدولًا زمنيًا
لها لأنني  كما تعلمون ، فإن الحرب
لا يمكن التنبؤ بها وكيف أن التطورات في
ساحة المعركة سيكون لها
تأثير كبير على كيفية تطور التطورات على
طاولة المفاوضات ولكن ما
سأقوله هو أن هذا الرئيس زيلينسكي نفسه
قال إن هذه الحرب ستنتهي في
نهاية المطاف من خلال الدبلوماسية وكما
سمعتم.  من الوزير بلينكين في خطاب
ألقاه هذا الأسبوع ، تعتقد الولايات المتحدة
أن أي سلام عادل يجب أن يقوم
على بعض المبادئ التأسيسية ،
أحد هذه المبادئ متجذر في
ميثاق الأمم المتحدة وهو
مبدأ السيادة والسلامة الإقليمية
وبالمناسبة  البلدان
التي وصفتها في
بيانك الافتتاحي سواء كانت الهند أو تركيا
أو إندونيسيا أو غيرها تحدثوا جميعًا
عن الحاجة إلى حماية
مبدأ السيادة والسلامة الإقليمية ، فقد
صوتت البرازيل على سبيل المثال
لصالح قرارات الجمعية العامة للأمم المتحدة
التي تدعم
أراضي أوكرانيا  النزاهة أشارت الدول الأخرى
في كل من القطاعين العام والخاص إلى
أن هذا هو Cena Quan المعروف
بتسوية عادلة وعادلة هنا ، لذا هذا
ما سنقود من أجله ، هل
تعتقد أن الصين
تبدو الآن تريد الدخول في روسيا
أوكرانيا أه إرسال المفاوضات  أه
المبعوث الذي تحدثت مع زيلينسكي كلها
هذه التحركات المهمة التي تشير إلى
أن الصين ستمارس بعض الضغط على
روسيا للتراجع بطريقة ما ،
نعتقد أن الصين يجب أن تلعب
دورًا بناء في المساعدة في
إنهاء الحرب في  أوكرانيا
وهذا يعود إلى نفس المبدأ الذي كنت
أتحدث عنه منذ دقيقة واحدة وهو
مبدأ السيادة
ووحدة الأراضي ، وفي الواقع إذا نظرت إلى
المبادئ الاثني عشر التي طرحتها الصين في
معادلة السلام ، فإن المبدأ الأول كان
أنه يتعلق بالحرمة
لسيادة دولة ما وحقيقة أنه
لا ينبغي تغيير الحدود بالقوة ،
لذا فإن الأمر متروك للصين لاتخاذ
قرارها بشأن ما إذا كانت
ستميل إلى هنا
لدعم مبدأ السيادة هذا
والإشارة إلى روسيا بأنها
ستقف  وراء النتيجة التي
تستعيد فيها أوكرانيا سيادتها سواء
فعلت الصين ذلك أم لا ، ليس من الواضح أنهم
كانوا مترددين حتى الآن أعتقد أنهم
ما زالوا يحاولون تحديد كيف يريدون
المضي قدمًا ولكننا ندعم جمهورية الصين الشعبية التي تلعب
دورًا بناءً.  في مقال عادل
بناءً على مبادئ
ميثاق الأمم المتحدة ، أجرى هنري كيسنجر الذي بلغ 100 عامًا أو
بلغ 100 عامًا هذا العام
مقابلة في The Economist
قال فيها إنه يعتقد أن العلاقات الأمريكية مع الصين
كانت في فترة ما قبل الحرب العالمية الكلاسيكية.
حالة واحدة لم يشعر فيها أي من الطرفين أن
لديه أي مساحة سياسية لتقديم
تنازلات أو لتقديم مبادرات وأن
التضمين كان نوعًا من
التعثر في طريقنا إلى شيء
يمكن أن يتحول إلى صراع خطير للغاية ،
هل توافق على
أنني جلست في الغرفة مع  الرئيس بايدن
عندما التقى بالرئيس الحادي عشر وبالي
العام الماضي ولم تكن تلك تجربتي ،
رأيت قائدين كانا
يحاولان بالفعل التوصل إلى تفاهم حتى لو كانت
لدينا وجهات نظر مختلفة وحتى
لو كنا في علاقة تنافسية للغاية
في بعض  الأساسيات
في هذه الديناميكية والرغبة في كلا
الجزأين لوضع أرضية تحت
العلاقة لإدارة المنافسة
بمسؤولية لضمان
عدم تحول المنافسة إلى صراع وهناك
عدد من العناصر المختلفة لذلك ولكن
أحد العناصر الرئيسية هو أنه  لدينا
منافسة شديدة ، ولدينا أيضًا
دبلوماسية مكثفة ، لذا جلست لمدة
يومين مع نظيري وانغ يي
وأتحدث عن جميع القضايا الاستراتيجية
في علاقتنا ، وآمل أن
نرى قريبًا المسؤولين الأمريكيين يشاركون على
مستويات عالية مع نظرائهم الصينيين
خلال الأشهر المقبلة
لمواصلة هذا العمل ، وبعد ذلك في
مرحلة ما ، سنرى الرئيس بايدن
الحادي عشر يعود معًا مرة أخرى ،
وبقدر ما أشعر بالقلق ، لا يوجد
شيء يتعارض مع
التنافس بقوة في
المجالات المهمة في الاقتصاد و  التكنولوجيا
والتأكد أيضًا من أن المنافسة
لا تتحول إلى صراع أو مواجهة
وهذا هو الاقتناع الراسخ من الرئيس
بايدن وهو كيف
سيدير ​​هذه العلاقة بمسؤولية ونعتقد أنه لا يوجد
شيء حتمي حول
نوع من الصراع أو الحرب الباردة بين
الولايات المتحدة و  الصين
لذلك قامت الولايات المتحدة والصين
بتجارة 700 مليار دولار مع بعضهما
البعض في العام الماضي ،
فهل هدفك هو السماح لهذه التجارة
بالتوسع وأن يشارك كلا الجانبين
في نوع من الفطيرة المتنامية أو
هل تعتقد ذلك  يجب أن يكون هناك المزيد من
الفصل بين أن هذه الأرقام تحتاج
إلى أن تظل راكدة أو ربما تنخفض
بشكل جيد إذا اجتمعت مجموعة الدول السبع في هيروشيما ،
الديمقراطيات الغربية الرئيسية معًا حول
صيغة بسيطة نحن للتخلص من المخاطر
وليس للفصل ، نحن لا نتطلع إلى
الفصل  اقتصادنا من الصين
لا نتطلع إلى إنهاء التجارة بين
الولايات المتحدة والصين ولكننا
نتطلع إلى التخلص من المخاطر ، ما الذي يعنيه ذلك
يعني ثلاثة أشياء أولاً ، فهذا يعني
أننا بحاجة إلى سلاسل توريد آمنة ومرنة
في السلع الهامة مثل
تقنيات الطاقة النظيفة  وأشباه الموصلات
حتى لا نعتمد على أي
دولة
ثانية ، فهذا يعني أننا بحاجة إلى حماية
تقنياتنا الأكثر تقدمًا
خاصة تلك التي لها
تطبيقات عسكرية بحيث
لا يمكن استخدام هذه التقنيات للإضرار بأمننا
وثالثًا يعني أننا بحاجة إلى
الاستثمار بشكل أساسي  في مصادر
قدرتنا الصناعية هنا في المنزل
حتى نتمتع بالقدرة على النمو
وإنتاج بعض السلع الأساسية التي
سنحتاج إلى الاعتماد عليها في
السنوات المقبلة سواء كان ذلك في مجال
التكنولوجيا أو الصحة أو النظافة  الطاقة
وهذا ما ننوي القيام به حتى لا
نفصل